für wen wir wirklich lernen in der
schule dieser kontroverse sind wir
nachgegangen
eine gut schweizerische tradition wenn
es um reformen geht wird die schulstube
zur kampfzone in der alle mit fechten
wolle pädagogen politiker eltern ein
einziger lehrplan ersetzt 21 kantonale
lehrpläne
das erleichtert wohnortswechsel und wird
nicht in frage gestellt 5 stoff gibt
aber der bildungsauftrag des lehrplans
21 nicht mehr nur der schulstoff zählt
sondern vor allem dass die schüler ihn
anwenden können kompetenzorientierung
heißt das zauberwort
und dieser begriff spaltet die pädagogen
gemeinde
roland reichenbach pädagogik professor
der universität zürich hat seine
vorbehalte
was ich nicht überzeugend finde ich die
durchgängige orientierung der
kompetenzen und wenn man das war korrekt
dass ich wirklich glücklich
es ist seine sticks werk und das wort
können rund 100 ihm formal vor und das
set der serie große monotonie
dann können oder gefragt ich muss
wirklich alles kompetenz theoretisch
irgendwas wird
er ist auch pädagogik professor an der
uni zürich aber urs moser ist ein
verfechter der kompetenzorientierung
kompetenz zwischen neuer begriff für
episode schon immer gemacht hat das ziel
für die schule ist das meer im
unterricht wisse und körner vermietet
beetes es geht nicht nur darum dass ein
fax der wissen vermittelt und gas wieder
fließt sondern das muss versteuert und
finde ich die anderen kontext auch
simpel und einfach kompetenzorientierung
heißt den fokus darauf legen was vom
unterricht hängen bleibt
die schule soll die schüler fit machen
für beruf und gesellschaft
schließlich heißt es frei nach zenica
nicht für die schule lernen wir sondern
für das leben doch andersrum gefragt
muss schulstoff immer nützlich sein ist
schule nicht mehr als die vorstufe des
lebens denn bildung so sagen manche
dürfe nicht einfach ein werkzeugkasten
sein
bildung sei ein horizont-ausgabe macher
mit dem horizont aber mir hat die
perspektive
wir haben kontakt sie das könnt ihr
wichtig sie das heißt er findet es gut
dass alle schüler man blockflöte der
andere kam am schluss konflikt die
meisten it blog flotter spätes tor und
ohne gurt aber sehr blockflöte lang gab
es in kontakt und in die kultur dort
schuhe hätten das ermöglichen das wissen
und können
sind das wirklich die gesetze wird das
können werden kompetenzen im lehrplan 21
überbewertet und was sind eigentlich
kompetenzen
das ist selbst für fachleute nicht immer
klar
im lehrplan 21 ist die rede von sozial-
und handlungskompetenz und sprach und
bild kompetenz und methodischer und über
fachlicher kompetenz 363 kompetenzen mit
2300 abstufungen umfasst der lehrplan in
einer detailliertheit formuliert die
mitunter über das ziel hinausschießt die
frau witte bis nach fulda
das ist doch inneren unglückliche
formulierung der messe sehr lebens
dokument dass man mit viel wasser in den
nächsten jahren wird der lehrplan 21 in
der deutschschweiz nach und nach
eingeführt
falls er nicht in einzelnen kantonen
durch volksinitiativen zu fall gebracht
wird
eigentlich wäre gelassenheit angesagt
immer wieder werden lehrpläne
überarbeitet sie dienen vor allem als
planungsinstrument im unterrichtsalltag
sind sie richtschnur kein korsett
also sage wie sich zum beispiel
irgendeine lehrplan sieht auswirken
das weiß mich sowieso nicht für denn
hier wird natürlich wirksamkeit vor dem
lehrplan in der bevölkerung massiv
überschätzt
wenn der lehrplan nicht entscheidend ist
was dann
wir wissen es aus eigener erfahrung es
sind die lehrer
sie sind mentor vorbild und schlüssel
zum guten unterricht an welchen lehrplan
sie sich auch immer halten was macht die
gute lehrperson aus pädagoge reichenbach
zählt vier momente auf erst ist dass sie
zeigt dass das was sie unterrichtet für
wichtig halten dass sie das gar nicht
und sollte nicht ein museum wie zeige
posieren dass man das so lernen dass es
wichtig ist es etwas lernt und dann muss
ich zeigen dass ich das kann wenn ich
nun noch stimmt das ist dritter und
vierter moment tatsächlich auf wenn ich
probleme das lernen das heißt die vier
moment sie zeigen persönliche engagement
von apple soll
und ich würde jedem geben wir den
schulkindern für die zukunft nicht nur
güter lehrpläne sondern
lehrerpersönlichkeiten mit liebe und
leidenschaft
taxen streit